left-hander ryan yarbrough who is
6-5-205 the 28-year-old who was born in
austin texas this will be the second
start of this postseason for yarbrough
started and won game three
of the alcs against houston five to two
justin turner now with two out in the
bases empty turner as we mentioned
homered yesterday played outstanding
defense on the other side of the
scorecard two oh to turner did he do it
again
into deep center field keermeyer leaps
and that one's gone
back-to-back knights
justin turner
with a first inning
two out solo shot
and the dodgers lead one to nothing in
game four that by the way is
the twelfth
postseason home run in a dodgy uniform
for justin turner that is a franchise
record as he moves one spot ahead and
now all by himself in front of duke
snyder here's margot set below the
letters a rosary run to the pitch
swinging to mister down to second base
and randy is safe at second base the
dogs are going to ask for a review of
this call at second base did rosarita
come off the bag at all [ __ ] hernandez
with a good job of hanging on to the
ball
after applying the tag and he looks to
be out paul is out and the inning
is over no runs one hit nobody left
one-nothing dodgers lau with his two
home runs in the second game of the
series here's one into right hard hit
and bats up to grab it two down and
julio appreciates it my oh my like a
wide receiver making a bare-handed catch
leaping as far as he could he makes the
play and bench with another spectacular
defensive play in right field corey
seeger who lined to second base in his
first step back and seeger with a fly
ball to right field it's on its way and
it is gone a home run
corey seeger his eighth home run of the
post season the dodgers second home run
of the game
it is two to nothing in the third
it's only two to nothing l a raise it
right in this thing here is a shot in
their right center field this ball is
back at the one he's got
another and the all-time record for home
runs in a single post season
with number nine
more importantly for the rays it's a
two-to-one game randy arose arena are
the first pitch he sees here in the
fourth inning
has just gone oppo and the razor on the
board it's two to one two out as muncie
awaits the pitch from franklin seeger
leads from second that is hitting to
ride a base hit seeger is brought around
third throw by renfro has a great arm
but it's up the line
safe at second and now out as muncie
falls off
it's a three-to-one ball game and muncie
pleading his case he's delivered a
two-out rbi another one scoring with two
down and the two-run lead is back as
seeger
got to the plate before the out at
second hunter renfro leading off in the
fifth here is the 3-2 and a high fly
ball into left this ball is up and way
out of here
it's a 3-2 game as hunter renfro gets
his first to the world series his second
post-season homer he at the grand slam
of the series against
the toronto blue jays and right there he
got a pitch
that he did not miss
so the dodgers get a couple of gift
walks now [ __ ] hernandez is bounced out
twice hernandez he's hit into left field
pass a diving brusso
rounding third coming in to score is
smith arriving at third bases pollock
[ __ ] hernandez delivers a single to left
and the dodgers take a 4-2 lead helped
by two walks here in the sixth inning
another two out two strike rbi for the
los angeles dodgers
ray's trailing four to two in the sixth
inning rose arena at second and choi at
first infield shifts to the right
outfield straight away and here's lao
against fires swinging a fly ball left
center field towards the gap giving
chase's taylor all the way back to the
wall it's gone
a three-run homer for brandon lal the
rays have come all the way back and
they've got a 5-4 lead
yet another opposite field home run for
brandon loud just tucked it over the
wall out there where the raised bullpen
is
gave it a good swing got it on the big
part of the bat and just enough
for his third home run of this world
series going out here in the seventh
inning kevin kermit will be the back
there's a swing and a drive to right
field indeed back to the wall and when
this one lands we are high
meyer touches one off into right
kier kiermeier the 31st round pick
grew up in the organization
just crunched one
into right
seeker with a chance to put the dodgers
back on top
another one scores with two out and two
strikes he got to be kidding me
7-6 la
zieger on a bloop single to left his
fourth hit of the night the dodgers have
reclaimed the lead
it's seven to six it's two on with two
out and the rays are going to ask for
the biggest hit in the life of brett
phillips
here comes
[Applause]
oh they're trying to catch them in the
outfield and they can and it's got to be
one of the most unlikely endings to a
world series game in the history of
baseball the rays have won it eight to
seven on a base yet by phillips and a
comedy of errors by the los angeles
dodgers and this world series is tied at
two games apiece